[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight so here's a weird story
so many of those these days if you were
anywhere near the supreme court in
washington this past spring you may have
seen a black box truck with new jersey
plates and a billboard on the side
parked by the side of the road here's
the truck in case you can't read the
message it says briar retire it's time
for a black woman supreme court justice
there's no time to waste
those billboards were funded by a group
of progressive democrats called demand
justice which weirdly enough is run by
an extremely white guy called brian
fallon which is a little strange if you
think about it if brian fallon is so
passionate about giving leadership roles
to black women why hasn't he resigned
from his job and given it to one you
wonder that about a lot of people joe
biden for example in any case you got to
hand it to brian fallon either he is
remarkably prescient or someone in power
was listening to him
because just this morning was announced
that stephen breyer is indeed retiring
from the supreme court you'll notice the
passive construction there it was
announced
because breyer himself did not announce
his retirement it's not even clear briar
knew the announcement was going to
happen someone leaked that news with or
without justice breyer's consent they
didn't wait for him to do it himself why
because democrats understand they're
likely to lose the congress this
november they want to control briar's
seat while they still can
so what are they going to do with that
seat we don't need to guess joe biden
was very clear about his plans nearly
two years ago as he was running for
president he didn't tell us who's going
to do about covet or foreign policy or
the economy but he was very precise
about the supreme court here's biden in
march of 2020 on the debate stage at cnn
i committed that if i'm elected
president have an opportunity to appoint
someone to the courts we'll be i'll
appoint the first black woman to the
courts my cabinet my administration will
look like the country and i commit that
i will in fact appoint a pick a woman to
be vice president
i will appoint a black woman the supreme
court that was biden's promise all right
but which black woman exactly biden
didn't tell us
biden didn't mention the supreme court
nominee's legal qualifications or
judicial philosophy or ability to
perform one of the most important jobs
in the country he didn't even tell us
she was a nice person all he said was
she's going to be black and she's going
to be female because to him that's all
that mattered
you almost got the impression that joe
biden believes all black women are the
same they're identical it was certainly
the assumption in the delaware of joe
biden's youth 60 years ago biden doesn't
seem to have changed much
you wonder if anyone's sitting there in
cnn's audience that night even noticed
this
it's possible we've all marinated for so
long in the casual racism of affirmative
action that it seems normal now to
reduce human beings to their race but
imagine if this was happening to you how
would you feel you go to law school you
win a clerkship you get a seat on some
lower court one day you're nominated to
be one of the top nine judges in the
country and you're proud of that why
wouldn't you be your parents are proud
your friends are proud but joe biden all
joe biden can talk about is your skin
color
patronizing that doesn't even begin to
describe what this is this is exactly
why decent americans hated segregation
it dehumanized people
now biden claims that his race counting
is essential so that the court and the
rest of his administration quote looks
like america
of all the lies that joe biden tells
this could be the easiest to check we
have the latest census numbers and we
can promise you with dead certainty that
joe biden's nominees look nothing like
america not even close
is that a problem well the problem for
biden is that once he starts saying
things like this once it begins to
promise to represent every possible
ethnic voting bloc equally like some
ward boss in 1950 chicago
people are going to start to wonder
about their quote representation as long
as we're divvying up the spoils like
carrot cake where's my slice
so biden will nominate a black woman
great she'll represent about seven
percent of the population
but where's biden's pacific islander
nominee maisie hirono is probably
writing an outrage letter about that
right now no doubt she is
and why isn't there an american indian
on the court or a genderqueer or someone
from the chronic fatigue syndrome
community or a justice with cognitive
disabilities why isn't there an afghan
refugee under consideration
you can laugh but suddenly these are
entirely fair questions and by the way
joe biden you claim that trans lives
matter really do you really mean that
then prove it what kind of woman is this
anyway you plan to nominate what are her
pronouns
you can see where this is going it
always goes identity politics always
ends with tribal warfare
it's funny that biden people can't see
that
maybe they can see it and don't care or
maybe it's the entire point of the
exercise
whatever the explanation the white house
has no choice at this point to make good
on joe biden's promise the usual race
mongers spent all day demanding it
here's cnn
i mean it is a history-making moment it
will change the way the court
looks
and i think we cannot understate that
for this particular president where he
is today with a need to give something
that is of great importance to his
supporters people who put him in into
office especially black women this is a
really important moment i never had the
luxury of leaving any part of my
identity at the door before i walked
into a courtroom walked into a
boardroom walked onto these very sets on
cnn i brought with myself the entirety
of being a black woman the lived
experience of what that's like in a
country like this and i think it's
incumbent upon our country to recognize
that if we do not bring all of america
and the holistic views of people
including black women then we are doing
a disservice to any objective evaluation
of laws in this country
oh this is so great
that lady especially here you have the
most privileged people in the united
states of america telling you at high
volume with total certainty they're
victims
now that could describe most of cnn's
programming actually but today was
especially hysterical in music that
oppressed woman you just saw us called
laura coates laura coates went to an
expensive private school in minnesota
then she headed off to princeton and
then she went to law school now she's on
tv
all because of how victimized she has
been
it's almost enough enough to make you
like america when you learn that someone
that completely marginalized is now so
powerful sounds like a success story but
no explains laura coates in fact it's
still more evidence that america is an
evil and racist place
what would it be like for somebody on
the supreme court finally who looks like
you
i would be overjoyed and thrilled
how much does john king hate himself i
mean he's got to right on some level
saying stuff like that
what would it be like to finally see
someone in the supreme court looks like
you
thank god finally laura coates can have
some justice in this country at long
last maybe someone will send her to
princeton for free again just to make it
official she's been liberated
but wait a second
color counters what about clarence
thomas he sort of vaguely looks like
laura coates the lady you just saw on tv
same race anyway does he count no he
doesn't count
clarence thomas isn't a race monger he
believes in the constitution of the
united states he's supreme court justice
therefore
he's not really black see how that works
he doesn't count
so one of the potential nominees that
cnn has declared are authentically black
and therefore eligible for this job
let's see there's cherylin eiffel sharon
knife is not even a judge she's some
kind of political activist who works the
naacp her primary credential she listed
this prominently in her online biography
herself
is that she was one of glamour
magazine's women of the year in 2020.
laugh if you will but i mean why is that
not a qualification glamour magazine's
women of the year in 2020
send her forth to the supreme court
and then you look at her twitter page
eiffel's twitter page is full of racist
attacks against dreaded white people
here's one example from july of 2018
quote truth and reconciliation efforts
have little chance in many places
because whites view truth-telling as an
act of violence
really they do all whites
oh yes it's cheryl and eiffel they're
all the same same skin color same belief
now that's a common attitude on the left
it's not a reassuring attitude for a
supreme court justice we'll see how she
does
meanwhile cnn is also recommending a
woman called eunice lee now you just may
be a perfectly nice person we don't know
but she first became a judge in august
of 2021 that was let's do the math less
than six months ago
candace jackson aquaman has even less
experience than that she may be nice as
well but she reached the bench for the
first time in july of last year
the other nominees on cnn's list have
more judicial experience we'll give you
three guesses as to how they got that
experience how they get there wilhemina
mimi wright became an associate justice
on minnesota supreme court back in 2012.
now the sad thing about what we're about
to tell you is mimi wright may be the
best judge ever the smartest person ever
but as always the media minimized her
dehumanized her
in its coverage the media celebrated her
nomination not because of her legal
ability which they barely described but
because of the way she looks her skin
color
and that is a big part of why governor
mark dayton appointed her in the first
place he said that here's how the star
tribune covers her appointment quote
dayton's historic choice first black
female supreme court justice that was
the headline unmentioned is how she
might do on the supreme court again
nobody wins in identity politics the
people it's designed to help are
completely dehumanized and patronized
reduced to colors rather than human
beings
and in some cases the rest of us get
really crappy service because the best
people aren't being chosen that's just
true
ability is the only criterion that
matters skin color is relevant
katanji brown jackson got the same
treatment to be fair we should note that
unlike other candidates cnn is putting
forward brown jackson has authentically
suffered in her life she's not joking
she literally went to harvard with joy
reid
i i happen to know katangi brown jackson
i knew it was contention brown when we
were in college so i think she's
wonderful
imagine what that was like you went to
college with joy reid
i was in fallujah you went to college
with joy reid who suffered more
well after leaving the rough-and-tumble
of cambridge with joy reid brown jackson
wound up on the dc circuit court of
appeals last summer
or her credentials so here's how abc
news covered her confirmation at the
time they told us that jackson is quote
the first black woman confirmed to an
appellate court in a decade and should
now be one of five black female circuit
court is currently serving but hey who's
counting again you have to wonder brown
jackson we don't know maybe a super
great person really smart person
how would you feel if you were her
what about her achievements irrelevant
the media focused on her race and maybe
there was a reason for that because her
actual record as a judge honestly pretty
awful
she's been overturned unanimously by the
dc appellate court multiple times in
just the past few years
so you have to wonder at this point
since we're going by skin color and
gender why joe biden is ignoring the
obvious choice
why doesn't biden strike a real blow for
equity and just nominate bridget floyd
who's that was george floyd's sister
she's not a judge or a lawyer or
whatever but at this stage who cares
clearly that's not the point anymore
this law stuff
as nebraska senator roman ruska once
said in defense of one of richard
nixon's dumber judicial nominees quote
even if he is mediocre there are a lot
of mediocre judges and people and
lawyers they're entitled to a little
representation aren't they
well sure they are bridget floyd could
be a justice for the rest of us or at
least a slice of the rest of us
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else